Recently had good results with latest MRI appears resection, margins are clean,
now a tumor reduced in size from 10 centimeters to 1.8 centimeters. This person had surgical
resection. Plus, suspect lymph nodes are now are not visible of latest CT skin admittable on
the MRI, getting another MRI next week for additional detail based on radiologist recommendation.
It appears that the oncologist still recommends four to six sessions of port-based
full-fox or just five FU. I understand this is too weak in cancer cells and to prevent
distant metastasis. Yet this is also something that's going to weaken the immune system
and does not kill cancer stem cells. When I ask they say it's all about the immune system.
It's not all about the immune system. Thoughts on general on the chemo process,
I just don't want to take unnecessary risk, not sure what strategy is more risky either.
Okay, so my thoughts on doing chemo, if you had a debolking procedure where the cancer was
encapsulated and they're able to basically get the entire capsule, no need for a while if there's
probably circulated tumor cells elsewhere, that would not be a reason to do chemo. Like if you have
circulated tumor cells, there's no cancer, your PET scan is completely clean. Should a person do
chemo at that point? Yeah, that's real questionable. This case, you know that there's still some
cancer that's present. It's smaller. There's still some there. I would be more apt to say,
okay, I've gone this far to do the resection. I would be maybe willing to start to do the chemo
process and see how you do. Remember, some people petty genetically other detoxification pathways
and the health of their liver, they could just sail right through this and those are the people
that have fantastic results with the chemo and it did its job because you were able to get it out
of the body before it was able to damage any healthy cells. How are you going to know that? Well, the
only way that you're going to know that is to do one session at a time. So of course, I would
pray about it. Of course, I would give as much consideration as possible, but I wouldn't
completely rule it out. So my opinion, you're getting multiple people's opinions. My opinion,
I wouldn't rule it out. This could really put an end to your struggle that you had up to this
point by doing maybe only a couple of sessions. Maybe make a deal with the oncologist say, hey,
I'll be willing to agree session at a time here how I do with it. If I do well with the first
session, I'll move on to the second session. If you'll be willing to take another scan after three
sessions, something like that. I mean, that seems reasonable because honestly, if you said, well,
why are you recommending four to six sessions? The session, he's going to say, well, that's the
bottom line is because that's what is recommended by the pharmaceutical company. They might say, well,
that's what we've done and we've had great results. If you pushed that and said,
have you ever done three sessions? I mean, they wouldn't have an answer. So the truth is that, you know,
90% of the people just do what they tell them to do. So they don't test. There is no test whether
only one session is good or two sessions are good or who's who came up with the four to six sessions?
The pharmaceutical company. So there's nothing wrong with giving some pushback. You know, hey,
I'm willing to use my brain here that yeah, some chemo could really knock down what's left. But
you know, I'm the one that's in control of my body and I'll decide when I want to stop. But I would
like objective testing. Are you willing to do another MRI or CT scan? That's what I would say.